hello and welcome to this video this is
round two coverage of Tata Steel 2016
and I'm going to be honest with you that
wasn't the most exciting I won't ever
yeah this is not maybe a clever way to
start such a video people will maybe
switch it off and when I don't know turn
to some other two mother YouTube content
now I'm being honest there but I always
felt that it's better to be honest about
things and not yeah talk some nonsense
that wasn't very exciting today what
happened anyway I'm going through the
games there were some excited
interesting moments yeah it's not like
labid there wasn't any game in there
that will be probably talked about for a
couple of years or anything like that so
let's get going we had um seven games
and we have this I'm starting with the
game with a shortest name names yeah who
you found with right against Wesley so
yeah last year we had the pairing with
opposite colors and that word that meant
so was his home or something like that
soho whatever yeah let's see what will
happened here we had an e4 e5 opening so
who you found the best female player
currently she's going back to him to her
normal one year for and we got the
bullet hmm that's not very exciting
start to the game anyway we got d3m
Bishop c5 see three castles so we have
what we on quite often nowadays called
the declined Berlin not the end game the
famous Berlin Wall end game but wyd
going with d3 and see you three um it is
some usually believed that black has
very good equalizing chances here but at
least um more pieces stay on the board
that 97 maneuver is something that was
established in recent years as quite a
reliable way for
like to play the idea said after deform
black can take but he very often will go
back but didn't happen in the game
something similar happened but yeah this
is a very good way for black to play the
night wants to that was a wrong arrow
once to regroup to g6 and a capture only
five is not such a big deal if I was
also hanging so wyd went rookie one is
six Bishop a seven all very normal black
set up easily could have been from an
Italian game and in general the d3 Roy
or d3 against Berlin very much resembles
an Italian game so need into c5 an
interesting black uses his see pawn to
fight for the center and white close the
center now be five be three Bishop d7
all very normal and Stanley looking
moves there was one moment that i found
interesting all those moves look there
is standard and i think yeah a pretty
easy to understand night h2 white wants
to play Knight h2g for possibly and ya
know blacks move is quite ambitious so
plate see for tix Bishop f5 interesting
idea to open up the Queen side and maybe
complicate matters a little bit what
black establishes what has to cover c3
is that pawn on c4 now and with the
night on air form there are chances that
this night comes to d3 in fact this is
what happened in the game and it looked
like black has a temporary at least
initiative and the night came to d3 and
black double on the bee farm that looks
very active still it is not quite clear
how black is supposed to increase his
some
initiative or somehow get something
tangible out of it yeah the way it went
white got ideas like 90 xe4 not right
here but I mean the general idea and in
fact in the actual game we had after
some more maneuvers this situation d 6
is hanging and here all of a sudden can
why it was a poner la we have to look at
this a little bit if black Teague's then
Bishop takes is very good as this is
hanging so check the Restless of late
night e one chick and got his peas bag
and but wine is a polyp and there is no
clear way for black to get it back yeah
here Bishop a4 so I'm working at all
because of the d6 porn hanging and I had
to go back and now white is a pornhub
however um it turns out that black has a
very um yeah very solid blockade down on
c5 it does seem to be that wide can do
much it is nice with the porn but how
exactly are you going to ever get in c4
c5 in fact black sometimes is even able
to get Queens traded to just put it on
c5 after the caption Black has a very
basic fortress with King being on d6 and
then black just the shuffles yeah it's
quite funny still nowadays engines don't
get it yet stockfish gives why the
winning advantage while absolutely
nothing is going on yeah they I mean
what avoid it in the trade on c5 and
here they agree to draw there's simply
nothing going on the computer still
thinks white is winning easily even
though it is pretty obvious that nothing
concept here um black can even just put
the King here and on this just I mean
you just just stay you do absolutely
nothing just there is a barrier here
that white can never break and you can
yeah even various ways to do to get the
draw I mean this would even be a draw
without the h point for example okay not
a very exciting game yeah who you
thought had a an extra pawn for quite a
while in this game but still it didn't
feel like there was something yeah
something bad possible to happen to the
black player um okay let's look at the
next game and what kind of all I am I
going with yeah maybe I'll go by I know
length of the white players name so who
your fan is the first game second game
is Gary ding Liren that's four letters
um for both players actually yeah so we
have the two short name games they're
starting with that giri who orders ding
okay what do we get once before yeah
that's getting a really popular those c4
9003 g3 plank openings mostly because
people don't know what to do in many 45
lines like the Berlin of the marshal
yeah we get a Slav here by a
transposition and surprisingly digging
opts for this line it doesn't have the
best reputation yeah that kind of semi
Slav wear white has not played the night
yet I'm not saying it's believed to be
bad but usually the consensus is that
white should be a little bit better here
but mostly because of the possibility to
play 95 wear white gets a nice night on
e fire that cannot easily be expelled
this is the difference between having
the knight on c3 and on d 2 with the
diagonals still open here you can post
up that night this was not played by
geary however he played Queen to e2
um I saw in my preparation for this
video that this is um yeah also a
popular move and of course um it's it's
playable solid everything still I would
prefer 95 it's just a clearer way of
approaching the position that's just my
personal preference yeah ding went to go
see five on it I think it makes lots of
sense you get into that hanging porn
formation quickly and give me um yeah
quickly Transposer to that um he not
played Bishop a six that is the yeah
there is a standard way let's say to
proceed against the hanging pawns trade
of that bishop the idea is that after
the trade the light squares are somewhat
tender like be 56 be seven and also
sometimes the pawn however one should
not be underestimated here is that white
has a an absolutely misplaced night for
that kind of structure the night
absolutely wants to be on c3 in this
structure is just the opposite as what I
described earlier when that bishop was
supporting a night only five what Lex
here for why does any pressure on d5 and
the possibility to let me jump with a
night to be five the not only to pick is
entirely misplaced and this is the
reason why black seems to be quite okay
here Queen to e7 got rook centralized
Queen two is six and nine FYI you see
night f1 yeah the reason for that
nervous barely or is mostly that the 922
doesn't do anything and you want to kind
of yeah regroup your position and kind
of maybe make this more useful on g3
it's difficult to get it to some some
decent square while it's changing the e4
night it gets supported and now a trade
here Group C to rook c8
and drugs were doubled yeah what cannot
take as this is getting kind of
embarrassing it check Roxy one is normal
age five interesting move gaining some
space on the King side why not yet also
create some flight square for the king
queen ii jus h4 why not get some space
takes on c5 interesting moment now i
think that some players here would be
reluctant to play what ding played now
many would maybe opt for the beep on
capture and yeah play this position this
is not a bad position for black i mean
we don't you don't find anything and
terrible that can happen to black but as
I think in comparison that this still
holds a little bit more dangerous than
what he did he just took with the rook
getting into an IQ p position i think
that isolated queen point is often
avoided by amateur players because they
kind of pretty yeah the the static
weakness of their porn is often very
much overestimated and quite often the
porn it's no problem at all here this is
clearly the case there is absolutely no
pressure on the d5 pawn and black has
very active pieces as we see here with
the rooks the rooks in fact here got
traded and this is usually a signal if
you can trade off all the rooks that the
side with the isolated pawn doesn't have
many problems yeah it's a it's a good
rule of thumb if you play against the
iqp try to keep rooks heavy pieces on
the board and if you play with the IQ p
you should seek for peace activity first
and foremost but also you don't mind to
trade routes that much yeah it's good to
have minor pieces on but um but
susa trade and so in this position
nothing happens black is active and
nothing check can endanger him much here
we had a couple of more moves and in
turn i was just check this here and
takes only three and here they already
agree to a draw the consequence of this
is probably oops okay something like
that is probably going to happen where
Queen takes b3 now is some kind of come
on chan some kind of Perpetual or yeah
repetition so very correct game between
geary and ding Liren okay so if we go by
length of name of the white player the
game Adams Navarre eyes next pick that
one Adams no aria here we go so got a
coke on ya navara plays a couple of
openings you cannot really predict what
is doing is playing yeah almost
everything now so Carol kanya and Adams
goes through five um also em says some
played a fair share of limes lines
against the carrick only played them
panel of attack the advanced yeah the
classical with 92 93 this time it's the
advanced variation at its advanced with
age for not the main light but still
something that is seen regularly black
played h5 nowadays the main move for a
number of years also h6 was a move that
was played but ultimately I think um
black players decided that it's better
to stop g4 for good um yeah Adams now
played the move Bishop d3 this is Sir
not the most common continuation in fact
it is believed to be relatively weak
compared to what is normally done is the
move see form to attack that
and develop actively the bishop is often
not traded at all so quite surprising
that Bishop d3 was played navara took
lady six so we have some kind of French
structure now but with light squared
Bishop straited which can only be in
blacks interest the only issue for black
is that this h5 move sometimes can be a
weakness or g5 can be a weakness so this
Queen said formation can be tricky at
some and some moments however the way it
went Bishop g5 we should be 793 986
93-95 it didn't look very threatening
for black 92 and c5 the typical porn
lever here by Navarro if they both
played this rather quickly so it seems
that they were kind of familiar with
proceedings d takes you 5 and 9 a-6
black wants to get this pawn back
however chapter this sequence of moves
can which is quite forced Adams was able
to play the move before and keep that
pawn on c5 protected this look somewhat
dangerous young is black really able to
play this position without any problems
what about Knight takes before in fact
this is something that navara could have
played his move is ok but he could have
taken look B 1 a five King due to let's
say yeah if white plays here three here
there is this check and this is falling
yeah it looks like a 30 come on checks
to check and back here somewhere is also
not that much of a problem black as a
pawn up it's got Nazi for coming with
check and rook c8 c5 might pick up that
porn
White is definitely not better here so
black could have taken but the move that
Navarro plate b6 is also perfectly fine
it's in fact an idea that's rather
typical for lines where white is taking
on c5 and tries to keep the pawn that
black is trying to break up that whole
queenside often giving up a pawn to
activate its pieces and win one point
back takes takes it was the idea Knight
to g4 yeah of course white can try to
keep see to that way but after a takes
we see that the weakness of the a porn
is one particular idea in some cases
black can even play like that they're
giving up let be porn and play this
position now now your porn down but the
a porn is really weak and very likely
will fall this is looking quite nice the
NID force plate and after the trade and
the trade we get to precise is the same
structure a pawn this week rook be one a
root a to King de tu ere white cannot
take him as this is oops check
blundering the rook so King t2 and 96
yeah that looks nicer b6 is hanging but
if we do a count it's still equal
material yeah right only has gotten a
pawn back that on b6 and he had given on
a2 and blackest is active here we had a
couple of moments but check check and
check that Khan trade it we had get to
draw a creature yeah not very exciting
very correct on a game however sometimes
it looks uneventful if a white player
plays a somewhat let's say team opening
yeah and
the guy is playing precisely not much
happens next game going by the our order
is a young of ye my notes that are a bit
ly not very extensive so we had a um
yeah the invitation for a group fell
let's say yeah I think why he is more
gruenfelder than a king's indian player
but early on of course for the
fianchetto sister and the sea 65 line
which is arguably probably the best line
that black can play against the
fianchetto it makes an awful lot of
sense to yet to blunt the g2 bishop the
only reason why not more black players
play that line is that it is somewhat
somewhat unexcited at times wyd avant
trades on d5 and it gets very
symmetrical um any unloved course form a
sideline but sideline that has gained
popularity in recent times the move
Queen to a form um Garin looks a bit
mysterious this move what is this doing
the main idea is that if black plays um
the routine Bishop g7 then why does
happy to take and black then has to take
with the night due to the pin here and
while this is not the end of the world
at least um white has gotten a structure
with an extra center porn two against
one and in a structure like that the
mercy six also feels pretty useless so
black is usually avoiding the move
Bishop g7 in the London chest classics
um there was a game to par love Geary
when that ft seven was played cakes and
Knight b6 interesting no gear we had a
very decent position wide returned and
she takes and we got one of those
structures that I mentioned
with an open C file we're not much is
happening like it's um probably equal
close to equal not very exciting though
while he goes for a six that is a
movement has been played but it's still
rather rare the ideas that after cd5
black plays the move b5 why it goes back
and black takes the funny thing is if we
put put a couple of more moves on yeah
everything let's go here everything's
kind of symmetrical in a way but black
and spread a 6b five in the meantime
white has played Queen a forward back so
it looks like black has one to tempe
yeah but the to tempe were invested in
moves that are definitely not in black
sentra interest a cigs and b5 is
especially weakening the c5 square and
the whole Queen side so questionable
gain of time them form ye and on the
other hand you cannot really believe
that this can be decisive however I
think what is pretty good in this game
is it shows um how very yes circumspect
offense um can prevent any anything
troublesome from happening by years
defending this very very accurately and
I'll give you a couple of examples 95
and Bishop e7 demonstrated who should be
five yeah this kind of um sequence I
think looks pretty logical e6 92 and now
we come now there are a couple of
noteworthy moves one here is to move
Bishop to h6 this is a pretty good move
I can easily imagine that a weaker
player would go for something like 97
routine movement trading but here I
think white has some hopes that
something a group c 1 95 will ultimately
lead to very one-sided
position and the trade of the dark squid
bishops was very helpful the g7 bishop
might at some point help to cover the c5
square while the e5 bishop is not so
helpful for white in the fight of that
square so not trading this makes a lot
of sense this is why Bishop age 6 is a
very interesting idea and black still
retains the option of plague denied to
attack the Bishop e3 Queenie 7 air
before important move getting this idea
here we go Bishop activated also very
important step pawn to b4 Bishop to b5
check got those trades and now Knight g4
also a good move yeah black with the
trades got the Queen away from the D 1
square and now the bishop is attacked
well it's not hanging but black is
asking that Bishop what it will do yeah
Ln off went back to have four and after
the trades black went back and we see
that Black now has equalized yeah that
Bishop that was a potential problem
peace is on b5 and black has traded a
number of pieces here it is not yet or
it's not a danger anymore that the night
on c5 will cause trouble it in fact went
there but black called in a five now
here I was able to take the default porn
I was traded and now the black queen is
active enough to always harass the White
King here they agree to a draw so a very
uneventful looking game but I thought
that why you did a good job there of not
getting into any trouble with this
weekend Queens
this is the kind of chronic static
weakness that often costs weaker player
the game because they are not yeah
they're not precise enough in defending
a trading the wrong pieces things like
that and this just didn't happen here to
why he defended that quite not quite
nicely okay so what is the next game let
me not screw that kind of AD Wisconsin
right Carlton kawana that's a
seven-letter so we have to go with cards
now um so what did the world champion
play efore d4c 493 b3 b4 no none of
those it's 1g3 yeah he doesn't do that
it doesn't do that often but why not
it's not a bad move as far as i remember
I've never lost with the move 1g3 I
played it like three times or so the
span of more than 25 years okay of
course why can do that it's a very
transpositional move yeah with them to
the English opening to Loretta in fact
we got a very unconventional position
quickly Caruana when g6 Bishop to Bishop
g7 and now the movie for by Carlton
after five minute thought yeah so they
were really just playing chess now after
a couple of most white of course can
also go see for or default so with any
of its pommel say he defines the game or
the way the game progressive progresses
karana now p5 they're blocking the
center 92 and now an interesting move c5
not an easy decision yeah weakening the
d5 square but black gets a firm grip
over deform and with this kind of grip
you in some way ask this not only to
what it is doing it looks at very
protected squares um we already know
what can do a firm position we get it is
closed at the beginning of the game and
it's about
um both sides trying to open the game
favorably and we in fact get a pretty
interesting position d 396 Bishop e3
d620 294 interesting choice he was
probably afraid that see 3d for was
coming and wanted to get stall that a
little bit by getting the White Queen 32
but this is the idea why it wants to
push either d 4 + or F for one of the
two um cards now went for an interesting
idea you played H form using the H pawn
trying to provoke some kind of
concession on the Kings side it's not so
easy for black here to ignore the pawn
if you develop then h5 can be quite
annoying the move h6 for example would
ya cause some discomfort it's actually
rather normal to react to H form in such
a structure with the blur with the
vendetta to react with each h6 or h5
kawana goes with h6 h5 definitely also
was possible h5 g5 this is the idea
keeping it closed however keeping it
closed hmm not after F for quite a sharp
movie about the world champion and it
leads to interesting play that I think
that is somewhat better for white so
with this creative opening set up white
is gained i think a slight advantage um
yeah why by the way black has a couple
of weaknesses it's not clear where as
king is going age 6 poor King side is
weak and white is also a little bit
quicker and better develop businesses
it's hardly but is pieces a little bit
more active 96 and 93 here white also
had 92 that move was a very decent
alternative there should be 52 should be
three ish check for example can be
answered
King d1 the king is pretty safe on c2 I
think here white is better mostly
because of ideas of bishop h3 possibly
later Luke I've wanted to play on the F
file cons move whatever is not bad
either I think he has a has a slight
advantage all very normal and now the
chat Czechia to make the King King move
Queen to d7 yeah the move b5 look term
tempting but wide and pushes with Eva
all of a sudden and white is much better
so Queen d7 was played but now deform
yeah no fear pushing in front of the
porn the thing is that after TX takes
black cannot play the desirable move d5
as the e-file here gets opened up can
the check is losing material so karana
had to play this somewhat weird looking
move but it says all you move that that
works if white takes with the poor now
daddy takes that King as a problem yeah
if you go on the C file Lucy 8 is very
awful or if you play this black is
getting this back and this is happy with
this position so this is what why it
needs to do n t5 but she white
definitely has some advantage the
protectors PESA on d5 is strong and that
Bishop here feels somewhat stranded
Bishop g4 you should buy three takes
takes Queen B 5 the black Queen wants to
get some counter playing I think here
Carson makes a mistake or well I think
this is what the machine is giving what
the engines are giving um he played the
move Roxy one playing in a very yeah
direct sharp way not even covering the
b2 porn however it seems that he should
have played b 3 just keep that pawn and
shoot for this improvement later one key
point is that
if Jack gives the check wyd can without
any any issues actually step up to the
32 queen bee five you can go back to see
to possibly to be true and whites King
is completely safe the idea is that
after let's say before you just play I
capture capture I can actually just take
what I had in my notes was this and this
but I think oops I'm sorry rook see one
it's also not bad but what can also take
the pawn so the king is safe here it
looks a bit wacky to put it on d3 but
it's perfectly safe yeah cousin played
this he tried something else but yet
caruana gets enough counter play just
about yeah it looks pretty awful for
black hair with the white queen nia rook
may be ready to come but rook c8 is good
they have the rookies ready to join the
action and after Lucas one and clean
dehorn can check we had a couple of
checks and draw a greet yeah so bit of a
shame that the game ended so suddenly
after we had a interesting
unconventional position and it seemed
like a very good position for Carlton if
he would have played that b3 move
instead of Luke ASC one so probably a
spoiled opportunity here for them for
the world champion an interesting
opening choice was g3 and g4 just
completely going away from theoretical
battles um so next game then is kayaking
fun really yeah this is actually in the
game that will be shortest in my
coverage it was a bit strange to be
honest we had a a dragon yeah I am trans
position and yeah this is all theory
white is going for the typical attack
the uc's laugh attack against the dragon
this is a specific version of that term
with the early h4 h5 and 25 and this
seems to be all theoretically
no one and explored and it's something
that I just have to check database for
what what kind of predecessors are there
i'm not an expert at all we got a
position here after Bishop g5 that was
on the board just last year in the u.s.
championships and st. Louis between us
it's not a junior play anymore but it's
one of the younger promising American
players Daniel narrowed its key with
white playing Hikaru Nakamura with black
and he Nakamura played the somewhat
shocking new rook takes c3 not that the
ideas entirely shocking but he said
afterwards in the interview that
probably is not very sound that idea to
give the exchange here and yeah it
didn't feel a very sound in the next
couple of moves but narrowed its key
played a couple of em precise moves and
nakamura ultimately won the game quite
quickly i'll move 35 still that cannot
be great here i mean the kind of
sacrifice is normal in the dragon but it
feels very early yeah when really plays
the north king of 8 which is funny
laughs not even a novelty it has played
has been played in a in a german amateur
game that is following our game up to
move 20 funny enough i think without the
players knowing yeah they also spend
quite some time yet f4 nighty g8 king of
a by the way was played to preempt this
kind of thing that happening with f5 if
this happens with the king on GA then f
takes g6 is a threat so black it's
stepping out of that diagonal the
position is of course rather sharp and
after takes takes Knight takes for so
long Bishop takes it takes f5 rook e8 we
reach that position from that german
amateur game between mr. gugus and mr.
andreas viscosian now probably a german
league game i feel
that only gives Germany 2004 and both
players are rated 2076 and 2266
respectively mr. whiskey and i actually
have played in tournament chest um and
now we got the no team in that game in
the german amateur game that was Bishop
f4 plate and after root chicks at five
yeah Bishop f4 after Luke chicks at five
the position was entirely entirely
unclear even though black one and like
folds as Luke Texas seven was played
which is not working at all rook takes
Bishop takes rook f-35 Noah's plate it's
okay Queen f4 Kim g8 take stakes and
here white already resigned bit bit
early yeah but early you can still try
to muddy the waters but why does a what
is a piece down so what happened in our
game here can ya kun Phan vena you can
ask okay i can tell you kayaking played
the move Knight to d5 and offered the
draw yes you can do that then you can
just offer a draw in that tournament
they have no clear anti draw rule and to
us I'm pretty surprised that you offer
the wrong I don't think that why it is
much better here or I don't think that
kayaking is so much I know the favorites
over van valley that he should continue
here until the last porn but still it's
kind of unusual to have drawers offered
nowadays on 20 when the position still
feels like like interesting yeah I mean
sometimes you have some kind of opening
preparation where everything gets traded
and nothing happens i mean i have to say
that for example today i played it a
game in in the german league with black
against the 2500 player where I got my
opening prep and we trade it traded
traded there and and then he offered the
role on move I think it was 14 or 13 I'm
not quite sure and we played this draw
it was ok for the team it
wasn't completely unexamined this still
feels like some kind of game that can be
played it's a bit unusual that the
sample and kayaking is not the kind of
player who makes quick draw so I don't
know maybe there's some kind of
background story there and we shouldn't
be too harsh with with players sometimes
I mean everybody who has played
competitive tournament chance knows that
there are days where you feel like you
don't want to play chess because you
just um yeah I couldn't sleep at all and
not because you were in or whatever and
maybe in a situation like that if
kayaking offers a draw and when really
can with the draw get it would start to
that event why not agree to it so not
not going to throw any stones sale or
whatever and nurses and then listened in
Jones we have that saying I shouldn't
shouldn't blame people you are in the
same situation sometimes yourself okay
that was not very exciting nevertheless
and the final game clearly winning by
length of name is Thomas chef ski hood
wide against Mammadyarov yeah they
actually the two longest names competing
it's quite funny I didn't even plan for
that when i started the video but it's
really that too i started with the two
short names which is five letters in
combination or in addition and now we've
got too much ascii against Mammadyarov
it feels like which feels like yeah
super long words super long names and we
got a funny opening here d4 d5 c4 and
what did mamedyarov play now if you
follow his chest no more closely and you
might guess what is playing now even
though it still comes as kind of a shock
he plays move c5 this is something that
to be honest I didn't even know exists I
mean I know that it exists but not on on
any high-level it's called it doesn't
have a clear name but when I look
get this game now I actually found out
that there is a book published on that
called the double Queens gambit by
grandmaster bits gold off and it seems
to be invaluable opening always sought
it is bad and what I was always thinking
is that after C takes d5 this is what
Tomashevsky also played um that here
black plays this move Knight f6 after
which theory is known stating for a long
time stating that eva is better for what
and this is true it is really better for
why this is what I knew about this
opening all of it but mama JAMA of just
played coming takes d5 just take that
pawn and to be perfectly honest it
doesn't seem to be so terrible I played
90 of three logical cover that poor
black took it 93 the queen is attacked
it has to move again so it looks a
little bit yeah sorry if I'm Frank it
looks a little bit like a patsy opening
her black is moving the Queen early on
like two times but look at this it is
not bad at all why does taking on you
forward with the night a black plays
Knight f6 g3 very normally a white
cannot easily play the pawn and says
opinion the queen is doing some job down
g3 and now e5 all of a sudden now it
goes back Queen goes back and this is
not a bad position I mean black has
moved to screen three times but why it
has not gained much in the meantime
Bishop g2 leg gets pieces out laughs we
have open CNT file and everything is
kind of kind of easy for black I was
really surprised to see how how decent
moma drose position was I found games
that he had played earlier in this line
for example he played a strong Turkish
Grand Master last year in that line
where
then opponent mr. heelas played on
castles here in this position instead of
Bishop t2 Mammadyarov won that game so
interesting I never knew that this
opening was was kind of it's something
to be taken serious but it seems to be
black develops quite smoothly him and
Bishop g5 loops eh yeah all looks very
normal Black has got all these pieces
and play but ok mean I'm not saying it's
better but for such a such an
unconventional opening it's really a
great result yeah III now by an alien
love and black balls Knight a5 making
quite some sense putting pressure on the
queenside that gets traded on f6 and on
85 and i think around here the next two
or three moves early enough sorry
battalion of its Tomashevsky I'm sorry
for some reason I was thinking a lien
overs wide by too much chefs key yeah
deauxma chefs keys next couple of moves
they feel a little bit yeah they don't
quite add up I think I think you didn't
have a very clear concept at this point
this it looks like that you played the
move Queen to a form it looks logical
get that Queen out of the sea file but I
think Queenie for was a little more to
the point the idea of 24 is that um
white tries to play before this and a
for maybe two arrests that Bishop if
black plays on some slowish move for
example like i did in the game then
before and a form looks quite good one
idea of the Queen move by the way is to
get the Queen over here and possibly
play 94 officially for arrests the black
king a little bit i think the position
is roughly equal you played this me
forever and king g 7 a-3 bit slow yeah
bit slow now before doesn't make quite
some send as much sense as the move a4
is not possible the queen is blocking
this instead of
a three for example Bishop f3 was also
an idea you know the idea of this move
is that white sometimes has 94 so that
after Quincy one rook see one and so on
there is king g2 at the end and a
relevant line for this is for example
look T 2 after which 94 is pretty good
you know something like this now check
black can go back to d5 yeah but here
after something like g4 why does
somewhat better black's pieces are not
well coordinated look very yeah that
don't look ammonius at all Bishop f3m
was maybe a somewhat better than a three
now looked it too and now White has to
be precise Queen age 4 is still okay for
him but he played this move and after
this black is definitely better roop da
Queen d8 yes stepping out of the sea
file and yeah it's a bit awkward this is
hanging this is hanging and the Queen
doesn't have many squares rook c8 bishop
TX and before you should be 693 and here
Mammadyarov I think misses an
opportunity was Queen d3 he could have
gotten a pretty substantial advantage in
the game he also was better but this is
I feel like yeah what's even better like
it's attacking the knight and Bishop d7
can be very embarrassing for the Queen
and move like 94 for example after
Bishop d7 just wins for black no squares
white has to play something stupid like
b5 yeah now the only move and it just
loses Queen d3m there's only this reply
so the only move everything else loses
straight away but here also after Bishop
is six black has a very decent position
like takes takes very little squares
let's say three
Bishop c4 and this is troublesome really
the idea Queen f5 is looming in some
situations white can lose really quickly
if he plays stuff like that he will lose
now going back attacking the rook moves
winner 5 and widest losing this game
queen is just awful on a form 23 was
what's tricky really tricky i mean i'm
not i'm not sure if it wins straight
away but it gets gets very tough for
four wide ef5 still keeps an advantage
but what can I think be a little bit a
little bit relieved at least 95 and this
a this is still interesting mode you
played Bishop da now and this is a bit
surprising as Bishop d7 what's pretty
forcing the queen is hanging it only can
go to c4 and Bishop b6 it wins the Queen
now way it's a deadly pin White has to
give the Queen and takes takes this line
is totally forced you should be seven
Queen here and something like yeah
bishops is six tix b5 yeah and well I'm
not sure maybe why just draws this but I
still felt that this gives more winning
chances than the game he must have seen
that line it's it's pretty simple I mean
Bishop d7 is the first move your thing
off you attack the Queen it only has
that square there should be six it's the
pin it's completely force so maybe
Mammadyarov saw that and felt like okay
that's cool but I don't win this and he
went for Bishop d8 just keeping more
more pieces on more pressure on but it
feels like why this okay now can put
some more moves on the board bishop f1
bishop f6
yeah I mean black is still calling the
shots a little bit but probably it's not
enough to to do anything serious here
Bishop d7 was was more a bit more
testing than Bishop b5 but it's yeah
it's right it's probably has probably
enough to to make the draw and the way
it went we had yeah more traits we
should be 69 they didn't continue after
this but white will take and very likely
we get these two traded against one
another after which is a complete draw
so that video of a pretty uneventful Ron
still got 15 minutes yeah what can I do
but you got a pretty good overview of
what happened and after looking at the
games I actually feel like they were a
little bit more interesting their first
thought oh my god what a snooze fest but
there was some some interesting little
points in there anyway i hope you
enjoyed the coverage I'll be back
tomorrow for round three with hopefully
some decisive games there were seven
Ross thanks for watching us by mine